I've owned 1941 yeah where'd you live
Muhammad Charlie now I'm sure you my
opponent even Lebanon yeah sure they're
not picking up in he's from the American
Navy oh yeah right because you speak
great what you sound like you're from
New York yeah just like a chicken bone
Capone yes I'm not gonna better than
yellow your New York Mafia yeah yeah I
like like i remarried in yellow yeah and
you have the nice hair like him yeah
just like a in the young face yeah and i
can see you let you lift you lift
weights yeah
you guys still have each other this
guy's a character yeah yeah
from our tickets
are you meet here man two weeks I never
show not